and what happened is we left then that
was the end of it
and then
two and a half years ago 2019 2019
you know i'm split up i'm getting going
through the divorce the whole deal
and up on my facebook feeder page
comes
page
it's a video freaking facebook here we
go again the algorithm is hot on you bro
and she says hey guys uh today's a
really happy day
uh but it's kind of sad because it's the
end of my mom's bucket list
here i am on the great wall of china
about to spread her last of her ashes
and i was like holy [ __ ]
she actually really did what she said
she was gonna do and you know how many
people do that
very few yeah a lot of people think they
do but they don't a lot of people will
talk to talk but not walk the walk there
she is walking on the freaking great
wall of china spreading her mom's ashes
doing what she said she was going to do
that must have made you feel some type
of way no i've already i've been looking
like occasionally on facebook you know
just he was talking about it and
and that this just came up and i thought
i'm going to call her like i hadn't
talked to her in six and a half years
i literally picked up the phone how soon
after seeing that video did you call her
right as it was finishing boom yeah
and just called her and said listen
i just she answered no she used to i saw
him call did you pop up and i was like
i just started smiling i was like i
don't know what he's up about this
sneaky moment voicemail so you saw i did
but you said okay buddy
i let it go did you leave a voicemail of
course please tell us what that
voicemail sounded it was just yo i'm so
proud of you i i just saw your video on
face you know on facebook about
finishing your mom's bucket list i go
so many people never do what they say
they're gonna do
i always do your character was at the
top of the list wow i'm just proud of
you hung up
and then a few minutes later so you
check the voicemail
and then walk us through what's going on
in your mind then and i was like like my
heart started beating because i really
liked him when we dated like i thought
oh my gosh we have so much in common
he didn't see it i mean first of all the
names are ridiculous yeah paige
his birthday it's the same as my
father's so you know no daddy issues
um but also at the time um a couple more
things i was a yoga instructor too like
i was traveling the world but i took up
yoga because i had broken my back the
first time at 16
and it helped me train for all the
mountain climbing and ultra running and
so when i the arthur video really
resonated with me so when i saw him that
weekend it went viral in 2012 and i saw
him at the airport i the reason why i
went up to him not just like oh hey i
you know we're friends both friends with
ira it was because i said i want to
thank you for helping that man i said i
understand the back pain because i've
been in a body cast you know i had to
learn how to walk again and yoga has
helped me so much and i love that you're
reaching people through ddp yoga that
wouldn't take a class from a big tall
blonde he's a beat up older wrestler
with tattoos a man you know
so that's originally why it was so we
had that in common and um
the broken back i mean he got into yoga
because he blew out his back right so
when he broke up with me i never but i
was playing it cool like i didn't want
to be like i really really like you you
know and i was i mean i was getting
ready for a race in iceland and but when
he left you that voicemail and you were
playing it you're getting goosebumps
heart flutters what's going on i really
like to put out so i was like
please be separated from brenda because
i didn't want to like you know i didn't
want him to be that creepy guy because
he was always such a stand-up person
with me and so i was like please don't
be the guy who says he's separated and
so i called him back and he
congratulated me and i had asked him
like oh so how are things you know with
your wife and he said they were
separated so you're like yes sir yes
but you know this is this is a really
interesting part and
it was a while before we we met and
we're not that we at this point were
atlanta and nashville it's only three
hours three and a half hours
but we decided to
[Music]
talk and really get to know each other
it reminds me because i saved almost all
of them you know the texting because the
texting or letters from you know
john quincy adams the love letters he
wrote to his wife right
and how we went through this
period of really
getting to know each other like asking
the hard questions right before you guys
met up yes how long did you guys talk
three months three months before you met
up in person yes and then when you guys
met up in person wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait we're
there was something that happened over
this period of really getting to know
each other like i said ask me anything
because i'm not a liar i will tell you
open book open book especially
never doing it again like i there's
nothing i won't tell her or vice versa i
mean nothing
there's nothing
and
i don't ever have to think about
anything is that the
best approach in a relationship for me
full disclosure for me what are the
benefits of that because it's so open
with your lady well i'll give you the
thing that you sent me right before it
and i'll tell you why it worked because
it doesn't work with everybody because
other people they're different
and she sent me just one thing right
before we're about to see each other and
she said uh finding someone's true love
is finding someone who speaks your
language
so you don't spend an eternity
translating your soul
we speak each other's language
and if you don't speak each other's
language like my last when i was going
through the yo
because i was trying to save the
marriage towards the end or i should say
in the beginning of the end
and the freaking counselor was like you
guys are oil and water
like you do not belong together
i mean what that that's how i didn't say
it he said he's the guy who's supposed
to be pulling you together what does it
mean to speak each other's language
because obviously you're both speaking
english like that's not there's there's
a hidden meaning there what does it
actually mean to speak each other's
language what's the love language what
do you think paige
um i think though you know we're both
very open-minded people and we're
non-judgmental i think that's key we
also don't have any ulterior motives you
know i don't need his money you know i'm
i'm financially independent good baby
yeah i mean i don't have ddp money but
i'm fine and you know and i'm way low
maintenance um but we just
i don't know like we
i just always know he knows what i'm
thinking before i do you know and and
and it's vice versa with things we can
just little things we can
see which with each other like
i don't know we know the mood changes
and we just talk to each other we've
never had a fight in two and a half
years compare that to
when you said with your previous
relationship you spoke a different
language what does that mean
um it's like you know said right in the
beginning and that that that thing i
just said about you know
two people could pick up a couch really
easy yeah
that was chris rock and it was a
stand-up bit but it wasn't it was real
life because that's when comedy is the
most funny
but also the most heartwarming because
it's you know the angelo my look
angelo you know don't forget what you
said don't forget what you did but they
won't forget the way you made them feel
and when you have someone that you can
talk to
like there's nothing i won't tell her
because this is who i am like she said
to me right in the beginning
what would
my ex-wife say
are the three reasons why she's not with
you
not mine hers
and i gave him to her
and then i gave her mine
and then anything that we asked we just
completely oh god i wish i could find it
on here when i said how do you feel
about we actually have her on the phone
right now
no i don't mean her i i asked paige how
do you feel about entitlement i got a
real problem with entitlement yeah you
know i'll give you everything
but i don't just you know
assume
you know like do you think hot women
have a sense of entitlement that they
have not i think naturally earned i
think i think
universally i think a lot of people like
kids are really bad
you know really bad because they
entitled you know like right we got
plenty of money no no i have plenty of
money you gotta earn yours right that's
what shaq tells his kids right is that
i'm a multi-multi-millionaire you ain't
[ __ ] you got to go work for it right and
then and the people and i'm not telling
anybody how to raise their kids but the
people who freaking go out and and do
everything for their kids
they're really have most of them have
real challenges
[Music]